the reception area of the senate
minority leader's ornate office is
typically a buzz visitors and staffers
slip in and out meet chat and then move
on but on this day people made a point
to stick around
it's harry reid's last hurrah after 34
years in congress the senator shuffled
into the foyer for one final meet and
greet with nevada constituents
morning everybody
[Music]
nice to have everyone here
reed has never been comfortable with
many of the prerequisites of politics
glad handing baby kissing and such but
seems to enjoy the informal banter of
these weekly rituals that began when he
first came to washington
come on george nat where are you
great looking forward to what you got to
say as usual there's a smattering of
nevadans who happen to be in washington
but several of those who crowded into
the office have worked for reid at one
time or another and wanted to pay
respects on his last day does anyone
i'll have two or three people guess
during the 34 years i've been in
congress how many people do you think
i've had work me
okay who wants to guess
zach you gets
uh
1500. that's a lot yeah i was thinking a
thousand okay
almost 3 000. wow that amazing
and
i'm not going to say this on the floor
but
brigham young would be jealous i
consider them all my children
there's a change of anxiety floating
over the building in his inner office
down the hall boxes are already being
packed up and personal effects shipped
off reid is really leaving minutes later
the senator is scheduled to deliver his
final speech from the floor might he use
the occasion to unleash one final atomic
salvo on republicans or on the
president-elect no one's quite sure what
to expect the perception is that his
communications team is always scrambling
to explain or defend incendiary remarks
made by the boss to be totally honest
and i have just never felt that way i
and i really haven't he says what's on
his mind and you're in you never really
really know
what you're going to get but i think
that
in in my view i think that makes him who
he is
and i wouldn't want to change that
but for his final appearance on the
floor of the senate reed put away his
flamethrower he was introduced by
republican majority leader and arch
nemesis mitch mcconnell who said
gracious things about his longtime
adversary but through the years
we've come to understand some things
about
one another
and we've endeavored to keep our
disagreements professional
rather than personal
reid began his remarks with a surprise
of his own saying he and mcconnell had
somehow remained friends in private
despite their years of trench warfare in
public i want everyone to know here
mitch mcconnell is my friend the
farewell address was much longer than
reed's usual floor remarks and much less
partisan sprinkled throughout were
references to his family and his roots
the poor son of a hard rock miner from a
nowhere town called searchlight i just
didn't want to talk about searchlight i
was kind of embarrassed about it i mean
look it's kind of a crummy place
i didn't show people pictures of my home
many years later i was a young man
and i was in government
and alex haley the famous writer
who wrote the book roots was a speaker
at the university of nevada foundation
dinner in reno
and i he gave his speech it was stunning
i was so good
[Music]
and basically what he said to everyone
there and he directed i thought marks to
me of course he didn't but he said be
proud of who you are you can't escape
who you are
and i walked out of that event that
night
a different person
a new man
i became
harry reid the guy from searchlight
[Music]
[Music]
harry reid the guy from searchlight is
the highest ranking most powerful
nevadan to ever serve in washington the
politically well-traveled read will take
over the reins of the gaming commission
the klas tv archives have chronicled
every step of reed's amazing career as
far back as 1971 with hundreds of
stories dozens of interviews in
washington the zenith of that career the
higher he's risen the more polarizing
he's become as with everything else
opinions about reed are split along
partisan lines well perhaps that's the
secret to his success is that he's not a
typical politician but he knows how to
fight inside and get things done and he
has that soft voice that makes you lean
in to have to listen to what he says so
he is totally unscripted but ever so
effective he not only turned off a lot
of people in nevada
but again he became a very antagonistic
we're still a small state
and for us to have a person in a
position where they were ostensibly the
third most powerful person in the united
states
involved in every major decision having
a significant role
and harry being a great tactician
finding ways to get things done and at
the same time making sure nevada
benefited from it
that's a
a gap that
i don't know if we'll ever fill again as
a junior senator i preside over the
senate i usually do it in the morning
which means i'm forced to listen to the
bitter vulgar incoherent ramblings of
the minority leader i've often said that
the conservatives hate reid for many
reasons but one reason among all and
that is that he wins
conservatives don't mind a liberal who
loses
as long as they're winning but harry
reid was a winner thank god he's leaving
is my initial reaction my second
reaction is i did not know mormons use
drugs sometimes the overhand right works
sometimes it doesn't and i've tried a
little bit of
jabs
a few hooks and some overhand rights and
i think it's uh well we weren't always
successful i think we conveyed to the
american people that we cared we didn't
like the way things are going and we
weren't going to take it
i asked him if i'm lying now
coming up confrontations with the mob
and harry reid's humble origins here it
is
most humorous harry reid
[Music]
[Music]
this is a likeness of young harry here
oh yeah let me in high school
you like the the the school playboy kind
of a no i wasn't i wasn't playboy at all
i was a serious guy for those who only
know harry reid from his acerbic
speeches on the floor of the senate it's
hard to think of him as funny but his
friends know him to be wry and
self-deprecating back in 2006 during one
of our visits to his searchlight home he
used his high school yearbook to prove
it oh here it is i found it
here it is
most humorous harry reid
right next to the most attractive
there i am not so pretty but very funny
throughout the home were clues to the
inner reed these are all searchlight
butterflies these come from searchlight
a collection of local butterflies bits
and pieces of historical trivia oh and
this here's what i want to show you come
in the bathroom
now this is my prize
signed poster of the grateful dead harry
reid a deadhead jerry garcia bob weir
of course mickey hart who was my friend
in his hometown 55 miles south of las
vegas it's reed who's the rock star he'd
just been named senate majority leader
so the secret service didn't want us to
show the outside of his house back then
but everyone in tiny searchlight knew
where he lived hi harry how are you
reed is the town's most famous native
son at the nugget casino he's greeted
warmly coffee worth a dime i don't think
so nonsense oh tony good to see you yeah
congratulations chatting with a reporter
in a coffee shop he is frequently
interrupted yes we're going to do
how are you
what's your name and of course they know
him at the little history museum my
grandmother used these all the time reid
literally wrote the history of
searchlight he once read from his book
for more than seven straight hours on
the floor of the senate as a filibuster
tactic searchlight and how it got its
name and mentioned the town hundreds of
other times in public the book's title
the little camp that didn't fail could
be a metaphor for reed's political
career harry's upbringing was as as
rural as you can get in nevada
searchlight
was a spot on a highway and it wasn't
much more than that it had a history bob
stoddahl the dean of nevada broadcasters
has covered reed's public career since
the start and thinks the senator's blunt
style was born in that dusty mining tail
i think that comes out of his roots of
the challenges that he had
as uh
as a child and and being brought up in
in searchlight in the battles that he
had to fight the photo shows a young
reed in front of the house where he was
born and grew up the toilet was an
outhouse his father a hard rock miner
drank too much his mother did laundry
for the town's leading industry brothels
in his biography reed wrote that he
learned to swim at a whorehouse there
was no religion in the reed home no
family doctor either in his final
interview as a senator reid recalled the
conversation with one of his brothers i
said larry somebody asked me
what we did for dental hygiene when we
were kids how often we brush our teeth
he said how could we brush our teeth we
didn't have toothbrushes
there was no high school in searchlight
so reed had to hitchhike the 46 miles to
attend basic high in henderson he was
active in sports and student government
which brought him to the attention of
his future mentor a brawling irishman
and war hero michael callahan not only
taught government he was the boxing
coach and the lanky reed learned how to
fight in the ring and in politics
michael callahan was harry's father
figure clearly and in the truest
definition psychological definition of
the word
i think that michael callahan
saw a bit of himself in in harry reid
and while you may look at it the other
way around that
harry saw
michael calais and that's who he wanted
to emulate
but i think michael callahan saw a
fighter a battler reed had a football
scholarship to utah state but needed
financial help to pursue his dream of
law school o'callaghan coaxed local
businessmen into contributing to reed's
college fund in cedar city reed embraced
the mormon religion and fell in love
with a jewish girl named landra gould
her parents didn't like it so the two
eloped the thing that's so incredible
about reid you may not like his style
you may not like his politics
but if there's a
horatio alger rags to rich's story
this is not just some political
fanciful
legend
it's true future nevada governor and
senator richard bryan had been an
upperclassman at basic high school but
didn't meet reid until the 1963 bar exam
in reno the financially strapped reed
was taking the exam before he had
finished law school he had persuaded the
bar examiners now this
this is a
an incredible story in itself to allow
him to take the bar and that upon his
graduation which i think occurred like
january of 64 he would be admitted both
men passed the bar then started their
legal careers in las vegas both had
political aspirations and by 1968 were
running for the state assembly in the
same district reid and brian were among
the nine winners they became the only
freshman lawmakers elected for the 1969
legislature and had much in common young
ambitious lawyers from las vegas who
both hoped to move up the ranks of
nevada's democratic party in carson city
they quickly became friends and
political allies other lawmakers called
them the gold dust twins and we were the
the goldust twins
in those days it's hard to portray it
this way but the legislature was
virtually devoid of partisanship
1968 saw considerable social unrest
across the country the gold dust twins
addressed many of the same issues they
would champion the rest of their lives a
waiting period for handgun purchases
consumer protection from big utilities
public lands they introduced more bills
than anyone ever a veteran lawmaker
finally advised reid and brian to take a
breath
swag camera came up to us one time and
said you know
this is not the last legislative session
that we'll meet you know but you can
take it easy guys
you don't have to get it all done you
know in one session but for harry reid
it was his only session as an
assemblyman bigger things were on the
horizon including the apparent death of
his political career and a resurrection
thanks to his face-off with organized
crime and today he pounded his gavel
in accordance with his commissioners
i call him a hypocrite
[Music]
you were my guest mr chairman senator at
the tangiers hotel did you not promise
me that i would have a favor he was
never your guest today you were never my
guest i never come to you i don't cop
you at least two or three times a month
in the scorsese film casino mob figure
ace rothstein throws a tantrum in front
of a mild-mannered nevada gaming
official in las vegas no one has to
guess the identity of that berated
commissioner by the time harry reid was
appointed to the gaming commission in
real life he was in the view of many a
political dead man or as reed himself
put it a 35 year old has been after
serving one term in the state assembly
the ambitious read took the advice of
his campaign manager don williams and
ran for lieutenant governor paired
together with his former high school
teacher and political mentor michael
callahan a decided underdog for governor
but reed and o'callaghan won at age 30
reed was the youngest lieutenant
governor in nevada history he was not
just the nominal lieutenant governor he
was for all intents and purposes kind of
an alter ego to the governor on a lot of
issues just four years later reed ran
for an open u.s senate seat and was
favored to beat former governor paul
laxalt at the time there were whispers
about how the laxalt family came up with
the money to build the ormsby house
casino in carson city when reed asked
for an explanation the wiley laxalt had
his sister respond sister
who was a nun
and she got up there talking about the
only vows that she'd ever made in her
life with chastity poverty and obedience
i mean the backlash
was enormous reed lost a laxalt by less
than 700 votes months later he ignored
the advice of political experts and ran
for mayor of las vegas against fellow
democrat bill brier a county
commissioner there were 68 commercials
bought and paid for by harry reid's
campaign agency reid was trounced and
for all intents and purposes he was
toast so at that point
reed is written off you know an early
career has flamed out but he was
resurrected from the dead by his friend
governor o'callaghan who in 1977
appointed reid as chairman of the nevada
gaming commission the industry faced
huge challenges at the time the mob was
moving out and corporations were moving
in federal investigators had exposed
massive skimming operations at several
strip hotels with millions of dollars
flowing to mafia families all over the
country mob ambassador tough tony
spelatro controlled street rackets and
protected the skim mob connected front
men like alan glick and frank lefty
rosenthal came under scrutiny they would
not even allow me a hearing when the
state tried to force the mercurial lefty
rosenthal out of the argent casinos it
led to an infamous confrontation in fact
i rode in the same car with mr
brian greenspun and had lunch with me
and
it blew up what blew up was was
rosenthal making allegations and
stalking around the room uh
out of control is that a lie too
journalist bob stoddahl remembers the
day of the rosenthal meltdown and reads
cool reaction and i believe there's
video that that just paul pushes in on a
tight shot of of of harry reid's face
what i was imagining reid was thinking
at that point
if this guy comes anywhere near me
i'm gonna cold [ __ ] it just
a boxer or somebody holds their temper
and lee just appears that frozen
but nobody worries about
trying to have some law
to regulate the regulators worse for
reid was the attention he got because of
a fast-talking sicilian show producer
named joe agusto who turned out to be
the mob's inside man at the tropicana
hotel fbi agents recorded augusto on a
phone call boasting to a mob boss that
he had several nevada public officials
in his pocket including someone he
called clean face that was very damaging
to read
because everybody thought it referred to
reid federal agents already viewed
nevada as an ethical cesspool and
launched several corruption
investigations during that era the fbi
and state both dug into augusto's
allegations for a full year reid was
under suspicion i don't like to talk
about stuff like this but this clean
face stuff was extremely difficult
my wife and i
you know had threats on our lives
bombing a car
questioning my integrity now another car
belonging to another gaming commissioner
has been wired to explode a bomb was
found attached to reed's car it was a
dangerous time mob bosses back east
wanted to sever connections between
themselves and the skimming
investigation so several people
connected to the scheme were murdered
lefty rosenthal barely survived a bomb
placed under his cadillac joe agusto
entered the witness protection program
but reed was still vulnerable one of the
things he didn't talk to the press about
was the
the the fear that was put into his
family at that time
he told me later about how
the shades through his front window
were bomb proof that they were they
would come down to change the entire
security system in my home his doors had
special locks on it there was real fear
in that family it's been a miserable
experience for me and my family
depressed because he was under suspicion
reed went to see governor o'callahan and
was prepared to resign and i said mike
maybe i should just
do something else
he said
you do that and you'll regret it the
rest of your life well that was into
that reid is a very tough
young man
it is very clean according to multiple
journalists who covered the story at the
time including organized crime muckraker
ned day reid was cleared by the fbi as
well as the state joe agusto a small
time hoodlum trying to reach the big
time threw a lot of names around not
only mine
agents came to believe that augusto was
simply bragging to his mob boss about
connections he didn't have several other
officials mentioned by augusto including
then district attorney bob biller were
also cleared they hired outside they
hired texas rangers to investigate harry
reid they hired accountants to go over
through all of his all of his financial
dealings and they couldn't find anything
there that would leak him to to that
they went through every one of his votes
to see if there's anything or
specifically tropicana
with anything specifically linked that
gave them an account they found nothing
although the clean face story still
surfaces from time to time reed's tenure
with the gaming commission was a success
and started the exorcism of the mob from
las vegas after a four-year term reed's
career was rejuvenated
[Music]
still ahead a new opponent nicknamed
two years ago
[Music]
because of our independent way of
thinking in nevada
partisan labels historically have had
little significance in our state
in recent years some have asserted that
only one party because of a popular
president
has successfully provided leadership to
nevada
the presence in this room today
of these men and women
amply testifies to the fallacy of that
argument when harry reid announced in
1986 that he would run for the u.s
senate he was flanked by an all-star
team of nevada democrats including three
nevada governors reporters covering the
carson city kickoff knew that reed would
need every bit of the assembled fire
power because in a sense his next
opponent was president ronald reagan the
honorable paul
and mrs
outgoing senator paul laxalt had
declared nevada as reagan country and
later coaxed his good friend into
visiting las vegas to help reed's
opponent jim santini a vote for santini
is a vote for a united states senate
that will keep america moving forward it
was the last campaign stop president
reagan ever made reid took it in stride
the president's popularity of course
can't be transferred he's a popular
president but i'm not running against
president reagan the reborn read had
easily won two races for congress both
against republican peggy cavnar and felt
ready to move up his political successes
often confounded the experts reed was
never a gifted orator lacked movie star
looks and hated attending social events
or galas i love a parade george what can
i say
but harry wasn't like that reid's
longtime colleague dick bryan says
there's no mystery about why reed was
able to defy political norms reed's
strength is his discipline
his toughness
his own
mastery of his own time
i mean he is always thinking
he is a
political
grand master of the political chess game
he's not at all a polish speaker by any
stretch of the imagination but i think
the guy is cunning and i think he's got
the wheels turning all the time about
what he's going to do i didn't make it
in life because my athletic prowess
i didn't make it because of my good
looks
i didn't make it because i'm a genius
i made it because i worked hard reed
overcame the influence of reagan and won
the race against santini he was easily
re-elected six years later in 1998 he
once again downplayed hardy labels and
claimed in his ads to be an independent
like nevada we don't want a nuclear
waste dump
in our backyard but that race against
republican john ensign was razor close
reed won by a mere 400 votes it was a
wake-up call reed saw the democratic
party in nevada was in trouble a little
more than a decade ago and he said all
right we're going to bring in people who
know what they're doing we're going to
get organized he gets the caucus
for us at the beginning when nevada
really gets the spotlight put on it
and all of these things built up a
powerful operation the senator took the
reins of the state party and created
what many have called the read machine
reed's hands-on involvement and
prodigious fundraising meant that he
called the shots often deciding which
candidates could run in which races he
was famous for meddling in every race up
and down the the ticket he was always
looking
to build the bench of the party and
keep people that he didn't think were
good candidates out of of the race uh
and keep people from running against him
in the future oh yeah absolutely that
was that was the probably the primary
motivation in this game of chess that he
was playing nevadan saul reads
fingerprints everywhere even when he
wasn't involved reed was described as
ruthless the meddler in chief
machiavellian one by one one way or
another potential rivals for his senate
seat including attorney general brian
sandoval and lieutenant governor brian
krolicki left the field of battle at
least temporarily give credit to him for
that and it's not that you like him or
like what he stands for but you know
what he was successful in what he did
learn from that learn from that if you
don't
it's going to be repeated again you work
for the state party but you work for
harry reid
you know you are a field organizer
on the coordinated campaign
and your precinct is north las vegas and
someone comes up to you and say who do
you work for
i work for the nevada democratic party i
work for harry reid
[Music]
[Applause]
reid has managed to win races he should
have lost scaring off potential rivals
who know that any fight with harry reid
will be bloody i said
i know how to dance
i know how to fight and i would rather
dance
but they forced me
much of the time to fight
and while i didn't like that i was not
going to back down from that fight
[Music]
[Music]
at a gathering of nevada progressives in
august 2016 harry reid
characteristically found a way to stifle
a bunch of flattery that was heading his
way by poking fun at himself
when i
reed is not prone to false modesty he's
proud of what he's done in washington
but the things he considers achievements
are the same things that infuriated his
opponents starting with public lands
although more than 80 percent of nevada
land is federally controlled reed did
his best to protect even more acreage to
the end he fought attempts to hand over
control of public lands to states to be
sold off mined or drilled even if the
people in the small counties
didn't want
wilderness
that's still not enough reason not to
have it as a congressman in the 80s he
overcame decades of opposition and
championed the creation of nevada's
first and only national park great basin
home to spectacular vistas and unique
species but he was just getting started
when i got
to congress we had a
few thousand acres of wilderness now we
have more than four million acres of
wilderness i'm so glad
saving that land
in its natural state for my children my
children's children for generations to
come one of the
great legacies of
this incredible country of ours is our
national parks in the last few days of
reed's career president obama handed
reid a parting gift in the form of two
new national monuments in nevada much to
the chagrin of republicans ranchers and
mining companies one was the 700
thousand acre basin and range area of
central nevada home to a mile-long earth
sculpture by artist michael heiser who
emerged from seclusion to say thanks i
don't speak
much about it but i can't say that
senator reid
was involved with this project it's not
40 years it's 50 years the second
national monument was gold butte a
stunning landscape east of lake mead
home to petroglyphs ancient artifacts
dazzling landscapes there's really a
cattle ranch and this is sort of the hub
for the cattle ranch and cliven bundy a
rancher whose family had illegally
grazed cattle on public lands for
decades
pressure from reed and environmental
groups brought the impasse to a head in
2014 a tense standoff between armed
protesters and law enforcement nearly
erupted into bloodshed the end result
was the opposite of what the bundys
wanted when the leaders from the
standoff were later arrested it
invigorated reed's argument that gold
butte deserved federal protection we
live in a country that people follow the
law and what went up in mesquite is not
very good i repeat what went on up there
is domestic tourism reed did not seal
off public lands he was the chief
proponent for renewable energy generated
from them he coaxed blm into fast
tracking the approval of solar plants
supported loan programs for solar
companies and in the end saw renewable
energy industries attract seven billion
dollars worth of investment to nevada
his support for renewable energy put him
on a collision course with big coal and
nevada's largest utility he held the
clean energy summit and at this clean
energy summit with
representatives of nv energy in the
audience he stood up and accused them of
murdering indians because of the
emissions from the uh plant at the
paiute indian reservation and uh it was
it was not a disguise thing it wasn't a
subtle thing he said they're literally
killing indians and nv energy uh
well i think was shocked when they heard
this they realized he was gonna
go after them pressure from reed led to
the closure of a coal-fired plant that
had been called the dirtiest in the
country and the cancellation of two new
coal plants in northern nevada in 1997
reed launched an annual lake tahoe
summit which brought together federal
and state authorities as well as other
luminaries to restore and protect
tahoe's waters at the 20th summit
president obama revealed one of the
roots of reed's environmentalism
searchlight sure didn't have much grass
to mow or many trees to climb it didn't
look like this
so when harry discovered
a lush
desert oasis down the road called
paiute spring
he fell in love
and when harry met landra
the love of his life
he couldn't wait to take her there but
when he got
to the green spring that harry
remembered
he was devastated to see that the place
had been trashed
and that day harry became an
environmentalist nevada does not
generate nuclear waste of any kind
therefore we shouldn't have to be the
garbage can for the rest of the country
opposition to a nuclear waste repository
at nevada's yucca mountain had started
with governor richard bryant and grew to
include nearly all of nevada's elected
officials but reed's influence sealed
the deal and buried the project at least
for now yucca mountain one example you
know the environment the worst
environmental impact could possibly ever
happen to our state
you know we all a lot of us fought it
but it was harry reid that made sure it
didn't happen reed was often at odds
with environmentalists because of his
long-standing support for nevada's
second biggest industry mining massive
gold mines have scarred the state but
reed the son of a minor repeatedly
blocked proposed changes to mining laws
although he saved thousands of mining
jobs in rural nevada he never earned the
support of those communities the mining
industry did great under harry reid and
yet uh the the residents the people go
to work in those mines are being told
that harry reid is the devil and a lot
of them actually actually believe that
three monkeys were cooked to death after
our news stories about former space
chimps being subjected to horrible
medical experiments in a government lab
reed recruited astronaut and senator
john glenn to help secure their release
to a sanctuary he led the fight to get
medical care and compensation for nevada
test site workers who contracted deadly
diseases working on nuclear testing
programs reed supported many classified
projects at area 51 but still can't talk
about them secured hundreds of millions
of dollars for nellis air base and the
creation of the drone warfare center at
indian springs he's credited with
bringing home a billion federal dollars
for the expansion of mccarran airport a
vital cog for nevada's tourism industry
you know that's true in our last
interview he finally used the word pork
i am not at all
regretful of the fact that i was
considered one of the biggest
bringers of pork home in the history of
the country and i i'm very happy to have
done that up next why doesn't he release
his tax returns that would solve it all
quickly when gaps and regrets
and my grandparents are buried here of
course it's been more than a decade
since harry reid showed us the spot
where he will one day be buried to as
many critics it can't happen soon enough
reed's influence has achieved mythic
status to the point that he gets blamed
for all sorts of things according to one
conspiracy theory reed engineered the
bundy ranch standoff so the land could
become the site of a chinese-owned solar
plan the career-ending injury he
suffered in early 2015 when exercise
equipment snapped smashing his eye and
breaking bones in his face was allegedly
a beating administered by either the mob
the bundys or his own brother depending
on who tells the story i didn't go bull
riding i was riding a motorcycle on
election night as a red wave swept over
america nevada went deep blue thanks to
the reed machine reeds hand-picked
candidates for senate and two
congressional seats one but allegations
were leveled that reed had rigged the
vote with busloads of non-citizens
reed's name was invoked in campaign ads
as if he were the
looking to pass the baton and who better
than his personal political prosecutor
catherine cortez-masto it's not an
accident reed became a target it was a
strategy his tendency to speak off the
cuff and to skewer opponents made it
easier for the other side to tee off
reed called donald trump a sexual
predator and human leech he should be
very careful about characterizing
somebody and as far as harry reid is
concerned listen i know you might want
to go down that road
i'm not going to respond to a dirty liar
reince priebus was responding to a now
infamous attack reed launched against
presidential candidate mitt romney
citing an anonymous source reid accused
romney of not paying taxes for 10 years
despite the howls of outrage reed
wouldn't back down churchill said that
the
way you feel you've accomplished
something is who your enemies are why
doesn't he release his tax returns that
would solve it all quickly wouldn't
later after romney released some of his
returns to prove he'd paid taxes in at
least two years reid was hardly
apologetic no regrets about mitt romney
about the koch brothers some people have
even called it mccarthyite
well they call it whatever they want
romney didn't win did he the fact is he
has been willing to say and do things
that a lot of senators a lot of national
political leaders would not say or do
and that's been to his credit if you're
a democrat to his detriment if you're a
republican or if you believe in
bipartisanship history professor michael
green thinks reed's rise in senate
leadership was based on two things
reed's mastery of senate rules and his
willingness to handle dirty jobs reid
felt the democrats had been wimpy in not
standing up to republican attacks so he
became their junkyard dog moving up in
the democratic leadership in the senate
he wasn't competing for attention he was
happy to stay in the background but he
was also happy to go out and take the
hit if he needed to take it and that
matters if i'm harry reid and i hear
them saying of me oh god he's evil we
can't beat him blah blah blah
i would have a very uh very happy smile
reed shocked washington's sensitivities
in 2004 when he publicly accused
president george w bush of being a liar
twice alan stock got into it with reid
during a live radio interview he made a
point of saying that every few minutes
no matter what we were talking about he
kept saying he's a liar he's a liar he's
a liar and that's that's all he said
um
and finally i i had to say to him with
all due respect i mean senator that's a
lot of crap and he and he got up and he
walked out he doesn't have a sensor
inside of him and i get the feeling from
him that he doesn't feel he has to reed
was known to raise hell with journalists
a lesson learned by steve sebelius the
longtime political columnist for the las
vegas review journal i remember once he
summoned me to his office and uh wanted
to talk to me written a column that
exonerated uh dr joe heck uh for the
delay in the
uh in the uh uh
taking up of the bill of immigration on
the on the house floor i said it wasn't
his fault harry reid was livid about
that and he told me that column made me
want to vomit
and proceeded at length to describe its
its flaws and
gotta go deficiencies was the harbinger
for the nastiest and most expensive race
in nevada history the tea party movement
had its raucous coming out party in of
all places searchlight the point was
pretty clear harry reid must go polls
showed reed an underdog to tea party
acolyte sharon angle who had plenty of
outside money to blast the incumbent
harry reid making a million dollars from
a sweetheart land deal you just trying
to make ends meet but the reed campaign
wanted to run against angle which is why
it intervened in the gop primary and
helped take out candidates who were seen
as a stronger threat to the senator in a
general election in what turned out to
be his final campaign reed won by a
solid margin three years later a gallup
poll called reed the most hated
congressional leader in america in part
because of perceived gridlock in
washington they want to close government
this is all a subterfuge
reed the tactician found ways to block
votes on bills that would have caused
political problems for democratic
senators he took the hit instead as
majority leader reed was pummeled with
more filibusters than at any time in u.s
history it wasn't
senator reid that was filibustering
those 400 500 times
it was it was republicans it was just
they made a decision to pose everything
that obama wanted to do
they considered him an illegitimate
president someone asked me that day
because he was black i said i've never
said that draw out of a conclusion
reid became obama's workhorse in
congress there would have been no
obamacare without reid's labors
ultimately reed made a tactical decision
and changed the filibuster rules the
so-called nuclear option which made it
tougher to filibuster bills or
appointments a decision that could haunt
democrats now that republicans control
both houses and the presidency over the
years reid was probed prodded and
investigated there were whiffs of
scandal with lobbyist and developer
harvey whittimore who went to prison for
bundling campaign money a utah
telemarketer named jeremy johnson who
said he plotted with others to bribe
read and a land deal involving reed's
friend of many years lobbyist jay brown
but reed was never charged with
wrongdoing in any of them
up next the political stars align to say
goodbye
[Music]
for the last event on his last day as
leader of senate democrats harry reid
and a select group of political
heavyweights gathered in the historic
kennedy caucus room for the unveiling of
reed's official portrait which had been
painted by one of his former staffers
one by one his longtime colleagues
heaped praise on reed and made him
squirm
my name is joe biden and i work for
harry reid
indeed
it's hard to imagine with all due
respect that we will ever see his like
again after a few weeks of taking
selfies in the woods i thought it would
be
a good idea to come out
and i am very grateful
to harry for inviting me to be part of
this celebration
as we celebrate a great leader and a
great senator and yes a great american
today we are hanging harry's portrait
here in the capitol but the more fitting
portrait of him
will be the one that goes in the
dictionary next to the word fighter
throughout his career
harry's fought the good fight harry reid
has yet to reveal what he plans to do
after the senate i ask him if he might
stick around congress maybe do some
lobbying his response was classic read
i'd rather be taken to indonesia and
kane he said no matter what he does just
the mention of his name will set off a
flurry of nasty comments as this program
most certainly will do love him or hate
him reed has been a central figure in
nevada history and on the national stage
in our last conversation i asked him
what his late mentor michael callahan
might have said at this moment he would
be happy about this
somebody would also say
you know don't take all this [ __ ] at
heart because you aren't such a big shot
after all
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you